Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday.
[inaudible] 11th,
2019 what's going on?
How I yeah.
Oh,
how you doing?
I'm in a great mood despite the fact that I missed that fucking the first moto
GP race of the,
of the year.
Uh,
I found out direct TV isn't,
uh,
doesn't have it on fucking television anymore out here,
which was very disappointing to me.
You know,
I couldn't find it.
I was scampering.
I woke up in a sweat going,
wait a minute.
Wait.
It says f one start today.
I know,
right?
Freaking out.
OCD.
Fucking 20.
Goddamn racist.
God forbid you miss one.
So I look up f one.
That doesn't start til next week down in Australia.
Okay.
I already have that recorded.
That's easy because that got picked up by ESPN.
So I'm like,
all right.
Where the fuck's the Moto GP?
I have direct TV.
All right.
I'm not trying to talk down to all you people.
That's right.
I can still afford to pay for cable.
That's how fucking hard.
I am crushing it
out here in these streets.
All you fucking cord cutters,
Huh?
Just backing yourself into a fucking entertainment corner.
Just sitting there.
I with your apps and your little Netflix fucking subscription.
That's your world.
Oh,
where are you going to do watch every episode of Narcos and then some stupid
documentary to try and impress your friends,
you what you need.
You need those 700 fucking channels that they have 300 of which are radio
stations.
What are you walking away from millennials now?
What are you afraid of?
They're all proud of it too.
Cause when I couldn't find it on direct TV,
I went onto the Twitter and very nicely,
dare I say eloquently.
I just put out to the Twitter sphere.
I said,
hey,
does anybody know what channel the Moto GP is on?
On,
on direct TV?
And Oh did the cops come out of the woodwork?
Jesus Christ.
You would've thought they put a fucking piece of cheese down in a bun.
All the fucking little rats that came running out right to rats.
Even eat cheese.
Don't they kind of eat anything?
You know what I mean?
Like if you just put like a severed finger in a mouse trap,
wouldn't have fucking Rad.
Eventually come up and try and eat the fucking thing.
I mean they don't give a shit right there like that relative that always shows
up to the event,
never brings anything and just hovers.
Right.
Hovers around the fucking table.
Doesn't use that fucking spoon,
you know,
to scoop.
It eases reaching in with his fucking meds.
That's what red sir.
Alright.
That's a rent and social Runkle.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
So I put it out there nicely.
Okay.
I like to feel like,
you know,
being a man in my fifties now than I am,
I am refined.
I am a man of the world.
All right.
I drive a four door sedan.
I still pay for cable.
Okay.
So I'm,
I'm like this close to buying a pair of loafers.
Do you want to stay at it?
Like that debt is like how established I am as an adult.
So I put it out there nicely.
Does anybody know what channel the MotoGP races on?
Uh,
on direct TV?
Oh these fucking cops come out of the woodwork.
I first of all,
you know 69 huh?
You got it.
Are you going to try that?
Uh Huh.
Right then they start doing this one birth and they start speaking in Twitter
speak.
I didn't know that directv was still a thing.
Oh wow man.
You're like so cool.
The way you,
the way you get your entertainment,
Jesus Christ,
you would've,
you would've thought I showed up with a fucking,
I dunno,
the wrong pair of sneakers on and what that was like in fifth grade.
The fact that I actually suggested I,
I,
I had no idea there was so much shame and still haven't direct TV.
I pay like 200 bucks a month for cable.
It's funny.
God,
what do you think?
I went from one fucking uh,
podcasts a week to two.
I've got to pay for my direct TV.
I to,
you know,
somebody told me one time,
he goes to you pay way too much money.
Just kept me come over there and I'll yell at him.
I'll cut it in half.
Cause all these fucking people.
A cord cutting and shit.
You can,
you know I have all this sports packages.
Oh yeah,
I'm talking shit.
Hit people.
Okay.
I pay for direct TV.
I have all four sports packages.
All right.
And I miss most of the Games.
Okay.
You want to talk about taking hundreds of just throwing them into a fire?
A lightness cigar.
That's how I'm rolling.
Um,
anyways,
so it turns out that directv no longer,
um,
Kerry's MotoGP,
which in my world is the best fucking racing out there as far as if you want to
see excitement.
If you want passing,
okay.
You,
you,
you fucking NASCAR guys down there.
Huh?
With your fucking stale.
That also doubles as a smoker during the tailgate.
You want to get drunk,
you stayed on this side.
If you want some buffalo,
you get on that side,
right?
You guys want to see fucking excitement.
If you want to see passing and that type of Shit,
you want to see a four.
Do you want to see a wreck?
Watch a fucking guy high side on a motorcycle going like fucking 200 miles an
hour.
Like once every three races.
There's just something that would make evil Knievel be like Jesus fucking crowds
.
That guy's still alive.
Which point you say it's called an airbag evil.
You know,
they watched you a little jump there and fucking Caesar's.
Who might say he evil Knievel would laugh at that bullshit.
The little light bikes in their fucking airbags.
You know,
he went out there wearing a fucking pair of leather under roos and gun on a
fucking chopper.
You can fucking buy down at the local store.
That fucking bike.
Way more than my goddamn head.
Um,
anyway.
do you want to watch this motor GP?
So I fucking,
and ended up going online.
Everybody's like,
why didn't you watch it on Reddit for free or whatever.
So I did,
I go to moto GP,
their website.
I sign up for this season 139 bucks.
Right?
More money,
more money.
Just fucking,
just flying out the window.
Right.
So,
um,
I signed up for it and then I'm such an old guy.
I couldn't figure out where to watch it.
And I finally figured it out after the race was over.
You've got to click on,
there's like four lines on the side and one of them says live.
And when you click on that,
that's the fucking race.
By the time I figured that out,
you know,
it's counting down like fucking,
9,000 hours until the next guy damn race.
So I missed it.
And like all MotoGP races said that sounded like it was exciting as hell.
And it came right down to the end.
And uh,
David CEO,
so beat Mark Knapp cares like he did last year by like the length of his bike.
And um,
I don't know.
I'm hoping if anybody you know,
watches it on Moto GP site,
if they replay it,
I can't even find a fucking highlight of it.
Um,
but anyways,
so all you read next down there,
who like your stock car racing,
just,
it's 20 something lapse.
It'll go by in two seconds.
And I know it's a bunch of foreigners out there on their little motorized
scooters.
I ain't,
ain't nobody named Kale or Harry or Dale,
you know,
there's a mark that's kind of an,
uh,
you know,
Andre's Davitt CEO.
So Jorge Lorenzo,
close the fucking border.
I'd like to build a wall around that fucking race tracks.
What the fuck?
I'd like to do.
Jump over that mother fucker.
Um,
so anyways,
I,
I might seem a little like,
my energy is a little higher,
little more giddy.
It's because,
uh,
I ain't doing shit.
I got a special in the can man.
And,
uh,
I'm just,
I haven't done stand up since I said goodnight night on the second show and a
tonight.
I'm actually going down to the,
um,
to the comedy store there.
It's close to the public.
It's just for comics only,
and it's the,
uh,
the memorial for Brody Stevens,
which I think is going to be a,
I think it's going to be great.
It's going to be sad,
but I really think it's like he's such an uplifting guy and it was so,
so much to learn from him that I,
I am really looking forward to,
uh,
to going down there and celebrating that guy's life and the work that he,
he did down at the comedy store,
one of the legends,
one of the legends.
Um,
there's a place out front where they put all the,
all the names of the people that really built that place and kept it going.
I hope they move his name up there.
That's what I'm going to,
uh,
suggest.
Um,
so anyway,
um,
yeah,
yeah.
All I did,
I took my daughter down to the park,
you know,
we went on the fucking,
all the rides and all that stuff.
Just said,
like the best time hanging out with her.
And um,
all right.
We said we watch the Bruins,
we watch the Celtics.
Why I watch the Bruins.
I watched three Bruins games as fucking weekend.
Um,
the panthers,
Ottawa,
which both ended great.
And then,
uh,
Pittsburgh,
I had a feeling they were going to get us.
I mean we literally one like 18 or 19 in a row undefeated,
you know,
we were like,
we're like 15.
Oh and four I think.
So at some point someone was going to have to stop us and uh,
uh,
the penguins always play as tough and as much as it sucked that the streak
ended.
It was our longest point streaks since I guess the early forties.
But um,
I gotta tell you some Sidney Crosby's pass in the second period.
Did anybody see that?
Jesus Christ.
Oh yeah.
That's one of the things you watch.
It's just like,
what do we need robots for?
Like that's like the kind of thing like a robot,
you know,
skating that fast,
trying to get around the defenseman and then he has another guy streaking down
on the outside of another diff,
a Defenseman,
and then you've got the goalie who could poke check the pass away.
He put it the only place where it could fucking be like a Tom Brady fucking pass
to the quarter of the end zone.
Yeah,
right on the tape bank bag in the back of the fucking that it was just one of
those.
It's one of those things,
even though the other team did it,
you can't even get mad.
You just like Jesus Christ.
That was fucking,
there was a thing of beauty.
Um,
so,
uh,
I don't have another fucking gig other than one quick benefit in New York that
I'm doing on,
um,
April 2nd garden of dreams,
at Msg,
uh,
in the theater where Eddie Murphy did raw.
I always think about that when I,
when I go down and do the show that,
that,
that this is where he did that special and I saw him on that tour.
Yeah.
What used to be called great words in Mansfield,
Massachusetts with the weather girls opening up.
I,
for the life of me,
cannot find any record of that date when it happened.
I think I finally found it.
What do you,
what are you fucking millennial nerds find that all right.
It was like 85 or in 1986 great woods had just opened Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
And that summer I saw,
I saw Rodney Dangerfield and this was post back to school.
He was that movie hit and he was on this huge tour.
Um,
and then,
uh,
I saw him.
And then that a couple of weeks later I saw Eddie Murphy.
And I remember that,
that really,
uh,
was something that stuck with me.
I was like 18 years old.
And um,
I remember when I went to see danger fields watching him and just looking around
at the crowd.
Um,
and it didn't dawn on me,
that was an all white crowd.
Cause I,
you know,
I'm white.
I was just like,
this is what the world looks like to me at that point in my life.
You know,
living in the safe suburbs of Boston,
Massachusetts was just a bunch of white people.
So it didn't really dawn on me.
That was an all white crowd.
And I remember looking around thinking about,
man,
this guy's making everybody laugh.
He's killing.
This is amazing.
Right?
And then a couple of weeks later I saw Eddie Murphy and the crowd was mixed.
And I remember that stuck with me.
I was like,
this guy,
but this guy,
this guy's making everybody laugh.
MMM.
I had lawn seats for that.
I had seats for Dangerfield,
so I actually saw him and,
uh,
it kills me that I didn't try and pony up some more money back then,
but I didn't have any money to not sit in the,
in,
in a fucking field.
I mean,
I didn't really technically see him.
I was just watching them on the monitors,
but he was wearing that purple,
a Mariachi suit that he wore.
MMM.
So anyway,
uh,
fuck am I talking about here?
How the hell did I get onto that?
Uh,
I dunno.
And I watched the Celtics versus the Lakers and,
uh,
at the risk of sounding like an old man,
just,
I fucking hate NBA hoop now.
You know,
it's just,
it's Jesus fuck up and down the fucking court.
Everybody launching a three.
There's nobody underneath,
you know the other teams on a 10 old run?
Yeah.
Just keep launching three's.
There's no feed and the big man down low anymore.
None of nobody can stand in the fucking paint.
Um,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck is going on with the Celtics.
I haven't watched too much,
but I watched a bunch the last couple of years and I can tell you this,
we had fucking Jae Crowder and Kelly Olynyk and everybody was fucking listening
to Brad Stevens.
We were a tougher team to beat.
We didn't have the level of talent,
but we were a tough team to beat and this whole fucking new era.
And you hear the announcers just like,
you know,
they,
they could don't,
the behavior that people get so good that they don't have to listen to the coach
anymore.
And I'm not just picking on the Celtics,
like that's like a round the fucking league and I don't know.
I don't,
you know,
he's going to have to get his touches.
Fuck is touches.
They're going out here to win the fucking game.
Yeah.
Drives me crazy.
We have this unbelievable chance right now.
Yeah.
With the talent talent that we have,
we should be able to at the very least scare the golden state warriors.
Um,
I know we beat him the other day in Regulus,
but that doesn't mean shit.
It's one game,
regular season.
Like those guys are the fucking champs.
They're in the middle of a fucking dynasty and they're going to have an entirely
different energy when you meet them in the finals.
All right?
As opposed to fucking one game out of 80 or whatever that you happen to catch
him on a fucking Wednesday night and you beat him.
Um,
we have this great opportunity to win another one while the Lakers are fucking
rebuilding.
And I love how everybody's like in panic mode,
like Magic Johnson of those guys are doing exactly what the fuck they said they
were going to do.
We brought in Lebron.
Okay.
This is a two year plan.
Like the,
the,
the fan base is,
they're so fucking impatient now,
like a two year plan is taken too long.
So it's literally you bring in fucking Lebron the first year and then he's going
to attract all of this free agent help and then they're all going to go out
there and pile on because everyone wants to be part of the Lakers fucking,
you know,
great history and they want to fuck models in famous women.
You know,
that's the fucking thing that they have over the Celtics.
They got the weather and they got the pussy.
We just can't fucking compete.
You know you want to go racist city to racist city where?
Right there.
Oh,
we got you eyeball to eyeball.
You want to go championships.
We got two more than they do.
Unless you count that Baa one that they count,
but they have the weather and they have the pussy and that,
that right fucking there.
You know what I mean?
The fuck are you going to do with the,
how do you,
how do you beat that
location,
location.
How many titles do you think that the fucking
Lakers would have had if they stayed in Minneapolis?
Okay.
And they had the exact same ownership
I'm asking,
can they still attract the level of talent that they attracted
being out there in Hollywood.
Now all of a sudden you're in the frozen Tundra of Minneapolis,
Minnesota,
right?
You got fucking farm fed chicks wearing their overalls coming in from Duluth.
Right.
You got some hay seeds making the trek in from fucking the Dakotas.
I mean,
I don't,
I just don't see it.
I just don't,
I just don't think there's enough pussy and you don't have the fucking weather,
whether in pussy have,
have,
have caused more goddamn athletes to make stupid fucking moves to jump out of
the NFL and join the fucking world football.
Well,
money to money whether and pussy,
the TRIFECTA.
Um,
so I don't know,
I'm just hoping people listen to Brad Stevens.
Just listen to what the fuck this guy says.
Play like a Goddamn team.
Fuck your own stats and just go out there and get it done and let's fucking win
another one before the lake is a common cause.
The Lakers are common.
They're always coming.
Okay.
It's almost like a rule.
They can only suck for like five fucking years before they're going to read.
And you know,
they're going to their whole fucking,
their whole fucking history is,
is,
is free agents,
free agents,
free.
Write down to Kobe Bryant who was a fucking,
uh,
Charlotte Hornet and what kills me,
you know,
look at that Antonio Brown like,
yeah,
you go into the bills,
you know,
I'm not playing for them.
What can they get the fuck out of the League?
Like I don't understand the bills just made a move to get one of the top
receivers in the league,
but he doesn't like where the fuck they are.
So he's not going to fucking go.
I mean that,
that,
I don't know what happened at parody in the fucking league.
I'd like,
listen,
I'm all for like players not getting fucked over by ownership,
but they're at the point now where they have too much power,
you know,
kind of like where the unions were when I was a kid,
which caused all these fucking corporations and be like,
all right,
well we'll just going to move the corporation out of this fucking country
and go back to sweatshop labor.
You know,
and I'm a I,
you know,
I don't mind you unions.
I'm not saying don't ever fucking union,
but who's kid.
No kidding.
And most people don't handle power well.
Right.
Then it became to Grady to conti too much leaning on the mop and then the
fucking rich guys.
We'll again,
we'll fucking out of here and I gotta tell you something.
All of what I've just said here,
I've,
no,
I don't think I've ever really read on it.
I've just,
this is all me just pasting together conversations I've heard throughout my
life.
Okay.
Well,
like I've said before,
if you want clear and accurate information,
you listen to the Joe Rogan podcast.
By the way,
I have to give that guy a shout out,
right?
Uh,
as far as like what that guy has done with his part,
have you been looking at the fucking guests at that guy's getting,
he's like Elon Musk and the doctor Phil and a David Lee Roth,
and then like some scientists that ever even heard of who then blows my mind
about like some sort of like a,
I dunno,
I know some scientific shit on a fucking,
I,
I'm too stupid understand it.
But like,
that guy is
like,
I don't know.
I don't know what school,
where this podcasting world's goes,
but like at this point,
if you do,
if you're a guest on his show,
you get more heat than if you do like I got fucking legendary talk show.
It's,
I don't know.
It's unbelievable what that guy is as has done.
I was just thinking the other day,
I forget what the fuck.
Yes.
Did I see,
I think once a David Lee Roth,
I think it was just the,
the variety of guests.
I mean,
again,
Doctor Phil,
that's fucking huge.
I mean that is like a big mainstream oldschool guests.
I'm going to go do the talk show circuit.
I'm gonna fucking go do terrestrial radio and all that.
You get that fucking guy,
me that.
I thought that that was a big,
you know,
I don't know.
That's a big moment.
That's,
that's right up there.
You know,
when Marin had Obama on?
Um,
I think when they look back at like,
what are these podcasts come from and what were some of the watershed moments
like I would say,
I dunno,
stamps.com starting to advertise and then it goes Obama on Mark Marin's and then
it's Joe Rogan's numbers and his wide variety of gay,
I mean he had like Elon Musk on his show.
The guy took a hit of a joint and it affected his stock prices.
That's fucking amazing.
Um,
anyways,
but meanwhile,
here I sit and my fucking sweatpants talking to myself,
stubborn,
stubborn German Irish guy.
It's just going to do it this way.
I don't want to talk to people,
man.
I'm not fucking with you.
I,
if you've noticed when I do interviews,
I'm,
a lot of times they're too busy thinking about what the fuck I want to say.
Or somebody says something and I drift off and then it becomes like that Chris
Farley thing where I'm just fucking grabbing the side of my pants going,
man,
when you did this?
Yeah,
it was awesome.
Um,
all right.
So,
oh,
Billy,
no booze bag.
Okay.
107 fucking days.
And I went to the gym yesterday and for the first time in like three years,
I did a dip testing out my shoulders.
Fortunately where I go to the gym,
they have like this,
uh,
the,
the dip machine,
you can actually remove the dip bar and adjust adjusted to your height.
So I have it just way down near the floor where my arms are actually straight
when I'm holding onto it.
And then I just sort of,
uh,
went up on my toes,
you know,
supporting my weight with my arms and went up on my toes like Michael Jackson,
and uh,
you know,
minus that documentary,
whatever the fuck is going on with that.
And I was just slowing myself down and every day,
every time I felt a little bit stronger.
And then yesterday I was like,
oh no,
I think I can do one.
I did one,
felt all right and then I kind of did three in a row and I was just like,
why did I just do that?
Because I'm finding with the,
the rotator cuff,
it's a,
is it rotator or wrote rotor cuff,
rotator cuff,
um,
rotor cuff.
Jesus Christ.
He,
me,
I've had this injury for three fucking years and I don't,
it's one of the,
you know,
I just had these words that I don't really know how to say.
So I just them fast.
Oh,
people don't notice rotator cuff.
Yeah.
Oh,
and at first I just think,
is it rotator cup?
A rotator cuff?
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Um,
if you're still listening,
God bless you.
That's all I can say.
So anyways,
I was able to do that and then they have one of those,
uh,
those,
those pull up machines that you can,
you know,
be on your knees,
would like to wait and all that stuff.
So I did like two or three of those and now it's fucking hilarious as I'm kind
of feeling a weird feeling in my other shoulder cause I think this one got worn
out because of the other one.
And,
um,
I think I'm finally,
I'm just going to go get an Mri on both of my shoulders,
figured out what the fuck's going on and then I might do a rogue,
but Rogan's been telling me to do is go fucking check out this guy that does the
stem cell thing and they just shoot it in there and all of a sudden you're like,
a fucking x meant I think I might do that.
You know,
I think I deserve that.
I didn't,
I didn't get the hair plugs right.
I'm not doing botox.
I'm aging naturally,
you know,
I don't think it's anything wrong with rebuilding the engine in my fucking
shoulders.
Oh Geez.
My kids screaming down there.
Um,
but anyways,
I haven't been drinking,
I haven't really been smoking and uh,
I dunno,
I'm actually calling a fucking therapist today to find,
cause I've been saying on my aunt stage of it and working on my anger,
but I've been kind of doing it on my own and I'm finally going to get some help
here.
And,
uh,
I've been doing this joke in my act sane,
like,
you know,
if I just didn't have a temper,
like
as far as like,
you know,
your wife's always,
trying to all say in a nice way,
tries.
He's always trying to help you become a better person.
Like I think if I got rid of my temper,
she would be out of suggestions,
you know,
because other than my temper,
I mean,
I'm fucking crushing it.
Do you understand that guys?
Do you understand that?
I am a man
that can still afford to pay for direct TV
900 channels,
350 of which are radio stations.
I don't even listen to those.
You know,
I'll fucking,
I'll pay for that direct TV subscription and then I'll order a UFC fight and a
sports package.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll fuck off.
I'll fucking stare at at $300 bill
pay it just like that.
I'm sorry I'm doing this.
I just was so shamed for still paying for fucking cable and I didn't,
I didn't,
I didn't know that yet.
I'm going to fucking doing this shit where I got.
Everything's like,
I like it all right there.
Oh my fucking TV.
And I watched this on my laptop.
I watch this on my phone.
I got this thing on my fucking pad bill.
They're all the same technology.
You can watch them anywhere.
I don't want to figure,
I don't want to figure it out.
You used to just fucking turn it on and that was it.
Three fucking channels.
Boom.
Oh,
do do.
Okay.
Woo.
All right.
You knew all the fucking socks.
Making the way in your world today.
Who can turn nowhere?
Dog with her smile.
Yeah.
Who can take her Harry rebuff and warm some cock up been Minneapolis while the
fucking Lakers have left out.
The all they show laugh and town is Mary Tyler Moore's pocket pussy.
Sorry.
Um,
all right,
let's read some a
threesome.
Advertising.
All right.
Oh,
look who's back everybody.
But at,
at,
at data,
all zip.
But girl,
you know,
hiring is a challenge,
but there's one place you can go where hiring is simple.
Okay.
Sometimes you want to go where higher ed people is fucking sue bull,
boom,
boom.
And it's fun.
[inaudible] you want to keep on fucking Busan without anybody giving you shit.
You want a with more alcohol licks.
Yep.
Sorry.
A place where growing businesses connected to qualified candidates.
That place is zip.com/burr zipper.
Her group sends your job to over 100 of the web's leading job boards.
Hey,
no,
stop that with their powerful matching technology exhibit at a retina scans
thousands of resumes to find people with the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job.
As applications come in,
zip
or man analyzes each one and spotlight spotlight's the top candidates.
So you never miss a great match.
Ziprecruiter is so effective that 80% of employers who post onZ ,
Eh,
we're good.
Yeah.
Get a quality of my,
uh,
my nod to motorcycle racing
the game.
Get a quality candidate through the site within the first day.
And right now my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free at this exclusive web
address.
Zip recruiter.com/bar that's ziprecruiter.com/bar.
Spell it out.
Zip,
C,
R,
U,
I t e r.com/barb ZipRecruiter,
the smartest way to hire.
All right,
look it.
I talked about them earlier in here they are stamps.com everybody sliding in
like Kramer on Seinfeld.
No one really has time to go to the post office.
You're busy.
Who's got the,
you got to be a busy looking at all and watching your gift,
your apps,
you know checkout fucking TV.
Are you watching?
Who's got time for all that traffic,
parking,
lugging all your mail and packages?
Let's get lugging male.
I mean Jesus Christ.
How many fucking envelopes do you have?
It's a pain in the ass.
We get it.
It's a real hassle,
man.
That's why you need stamps.com one of the most popular timesaving tools for
small businesses,
businesses,
distances,
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post office and saves you money with
discounts that you can get even at the post office.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of theU s postal service right to
your computer.
Whether you're a small office,
sending invoices and online sellers,
shipping out products,
or even a warehouse,
sending thousands of packages a day.
stamps.com can handle it all with ease.
Simply use your computer to print official US postage.
24 seven for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail,
anywhere you you want to send it.
Once your mail is ready,
just handed over to your mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox mail carrier.
You got that?
You see that that was,
that was Unisex.
Now Mailman,
not mailwoman mail carrier,
person,
carrier.
Why does it say male?
Um,
it's that simple.
With stamps.com you get 5 cents off every first class stamp and up to 40% of
priority mail.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the cost of those expensive postage meters.
stamps.com is a no brainer,
saving you time and money.
It's no wonder over 700,000 small businesses already used stamps.com not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost.
Oh wait,
I just went right back.
Hey,
I just was checking the time to see where I was at.
Sorry,
I'm not losing my mind here.
Right now.
My listeners get a special offer that includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any longterm commitment.
Just go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtryandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible],
B.
U.
R.
Okay,
there we go.
That was,
that was relatively painless,
right?
You know what I realized halfway through this,
I need to let somebody know that I'm not gonna be able to get to where the fuck
I'm supposed to be.
Anyways.
We plow forward here.
Okay.
Creepy Lennon Mannequin.
All right.
A couple of weeks ago I was in Liverpool and uh,
I went down to this,
this,
um,
oh,
it says right here,
Magical Beatles Museum.
Okay.
This,
I actually,
and I was making fun of that fucking John Lennon statue.
If you missed the episode,
you can literally,
the,
one of the first fucking things you see and it's like the white suit like,
oh fuck,
is that the white suit?
Why would that be out here in the open where anybody could just take it?
You Walk Up,
you realize it isn't the white suit,
you realize it doesn't look like fucking John Lennon and all,
it's got this awful beard like taped to the things face.
I mean it just,
it just looks like a rip off.
I mean they might as well.
I had a fucking two headed goat standing out there or something,
so I made fun of it.
So anyways,
it says hi belt.
I work at the Magical Beatles Museum and parentheses.
I like most of the staff agree with you.
The mannequin should be thrown in the river.
Mercy.
Okay.
The guys from cheap trick found it weird as well.
All right,
so that's a major fucking band with I believe that bands in the rock and roll
hall of fame and they are looking at it like,
dude,
what the fuck?
Um,
it's unfortunate.
You and your pal decided not to come in as the mannequins certainly does not
represent what is inside the museum is on three floors and is filled with 300
and counting genuine Beatles artifacts from 1959 to 1970.
So you know,
this is making me wish I went in there.
Well,
you got to get rid of that fucking mannequin.
Uh,
these include the metals John Lennon wore on the sergeant pepper cover.
Wow.
George Harrison's future Rama Guitar.
I didn't know what that is.
The spotlights from Abbey Road Studios,
Ringo Starr's,
snare drum,
Jesus seeds from Shea Stadium and the cello from the blue Jay way video,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
The owner of the museum,
also the guy responsible for the creepy mannequin is
rogue ASP Denali.
Best
I,
I couldn't tell if that was an affliction or a name.
It's a name.
Okay.
He's the son of
Neil Aspinall Lee Beatles roadie and head of apple records.
He's also brother of Pete best original Beatles Drummer and is a great guy.
Next time you were in Liverpool,
come in and we'll give you and your pals slash family of free tour.
All the best bill.
Fuck that dude.
I'm going to pay.
I'm gonna pay.
Although I would ask him.
It does Pete get upset that he started a fucking museum to the band that fired
him,
fired his brother has got it could be kind of weird.
Right.
Um,
I don't know.
I'm sure.
I'm sure Pete best is over it at this point.
Right?
I have one.
Is there any other,
you know,
that's another thing too,
on,
on Twitter.
I'm an old man.
I'm still on Twitter,
right?
I'm still on the Twitter.
So they had this,
this hashtag going around that said,
um,
not popular opinions.
And people would say like,
you know,
I don't know,
pick somebody like a,
I don't think it,
Dell has a good voice,
you know,
stupid shit.
Like nobody said that by the way.
Um,
I'm just happy I know how to say her name.
I was calling her to Adelaide for a long fucking time.
Um,
but somebody wrote that the Beatles are overrated.
That's another one.
That's a big one.
When millennials want to appear edgy,
they go,
they're overrated.
Oh,
are they?
Okay.
Well maybe if you read up on the history at some fucking point on cheese,
I get a phone call.
Hang on a second.
All right,
here's the thing about that.
I understand if the Beatles,
you're young and the Beatles music doesn't move you because I mean,
it's music from literally 50 fucking years ago at this point.
That's the end of their career too.
And then the other stuff is coming up on 60 years.
Okay.
So in defense,
you guys,
I understand that,
uh,
if you don't like it or does it,
but they're not overrated.
I mean,
they just,
they influenced an entire generation
of,
of bands to get started.
They made the whole fucking thing possible.
And because of them,
you're listening to the music that you're listening to today.
They are an undeniable part of music history.
But,
um,
I would never,
you know,
be this old guy going like,
if you told me that music sucks,
I'm not going to argue that.
That's just like,
I mean,
if I fucking grew up now,
I would like some of their songs.
Even I remember in the 80s,
like liking them in my teacher being like going like,
dude,
you don't get it.
You don't get how fucking huge it was when a Beatles album came out.
It's like the thrill,
the fucking world's stopped for younger people.
Then if you bought it and people do what I got to new Beatles album,
buddy came over and fucking listen to it.
It,
I,
I mean,
I wasn't even part of that,
so,
um,
but as far as like,
uh,
like furs,
he always [inaudible] hates the Beatles and he's just like yellow submarine,
Bill Yellow.
So I was like,
dude,
everybody's got a bad fucking joke in their rack.
C'Mon.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
you know,
versus,
whatever.
I,
it's,
I get it.
It's,
it's too much time has passed.
Um,
I've heard,
I've heard younger comics talk about some big comics that way and not get like,
what the big deal is.
But what happens is,
is the further,
like,
let's look at Beethoven.
Can you fucking imagine when that Shit first came out?
Like it just keep fucking sitting there.
You got a goddamn boil,
the size of my foot on the side of your fucking head.
You fight enough typhoid for a yellow feet,
whatever the fuck God damn plague.
And all of a sudden this guy just shows up with a hunter,
but his friends I,
yeah,
but like,
dude,
what the fuck?
You know?
And now you're just sitting there eating a subway sandwich in an elevator and in
the backgrounds gone butter,
Dah,
Dah.
Just it just something have the same fucking kick impact.
Um,
but that it doesn't mean the dude's overrated.
Does it?
I don't fucking know.
MMM.
Yeah.
Anyways,
moving ahead here.
Or if you look at you,
if you look at what is,
uh,
the salt,
you've watched soul train,
do you watch some of the people dancing from way fucking back then?
There's a lot of them that I've compared to today's standards.
I'm not talking about the legendary dances,
just people on the dance floor.
I just,
when I watch,
cause Nia loves that show and be just watching,
I just laugh going like,
you know,
there's a lot of people on this show that are dancing at a level that awful
white people dance at today.
Like the bar just keeps getting raised off of the work.
So if you go back,
the hardest thing to do when you go back in history is to block out what has
happened since then and try to put it into historical perspective,
which is practically impossible.
Um,
it's like going back and looking at Johnny Unitas,
how he threw for over 40,000 yards in his career and like the next closest guy
had half as much as that.
But now I like the way the rules have changed,
like a fucking,
like a Goddamn backup quarterback will throw for 30,000 in his career.
So it doesn't seem like a big deal.
Um,
so I dunno,
I'm just defending the Beatles,
that's all.
And I feel bad that I trust his fucking museum and I judged it by that goddamn
mannequin.
I think the whole purpose,
all that was me just realizing that I'm a bit of a cunt.
He's a bit of a con.
There he is.
He is a bit of a cunt.
Um,
Eric cheesy cheesing babies,
a dear Billy badge.
Have you seen these pussies throwing cheese onto their kids' faces?
I saw one of them.
It's just the fucking desperation for people to get views.
Yeah.
Um,
on the Internet to the appointment.
Look,
I'm a performer.
I have a desperation for it.
I get it on some level,
but when you start like the amount of videos I just see like parents with their
kids,
right.
And they're starting to fall and they don't do anything and they just film it so
they can laugh and they just like,
let their kid get hurt is,
you know,
the real ones like you can tell it wasn't set up is cause right as a kid starts
to fall,
like the,
you see the fucking phone flies out of frame and you actually missed the kid
falling down.
You can tell the parent lunged and tried to save the person.
But,
um,
yeah,
I don't get it anyways.
It's like how much the person said,
uh,
how much do you hate yourself that you'd throw cheese on a baby's face?
Just imagine what type of memory is sublimely stored where a baby sees a camera
and then something hit their face.
I'd arrest all these asshole parents and throw fire hose water in that at their
faces.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
I don't know if it does like psychological damage to the baby.
If you can even fucking remember it.
Like some day it's going to be in Philly and they're like,
hey,
you want to get a cheese steak?
It's like,
hey chase,
it fucking starts slamming a sandwich into his face.
Um,
I don't know that it does that.
There is just the thing where when you are,
you become a parent just sounded like defenseless and helpless.
You kid is,
um,
look,
I'm not advocating being
a helicopter parent.
I'm not saying that,
but
there's just something about filming it.
Like,
cause it's,
the kid obviously doesn't enjoy it obviously startles the kid and the fact that
you're putting your own fucking adult needs ahead of that.
I mean I,
I all of that,
that whole category is giving your kid a stupid fucking name like coat hanger or
some dumps,
Hollywood celebrity fucking name or,
or are
yeah,
putting your fucking political agenda like your kid is going to live your
political agenda.
I'm raising my kid gender neutral and then all of a sudden you could see his son
has to wear a fucking dress just so you can show off how fucking progressive you
are rather than asking the kid if he just wants a football instead.
You know what I mean?
Like you're going to make that decision.
I think all of that stuff is,
um,
I don't know what the,
I'm not a psychologist.
I,
I just,
it's not how I would do it,
you know?
I think he should,
if your kid starts to fall,
you should try to catch your kid.
I think if there's cheese,
you should hand it to your child.
If your kid wants to eat it,
they eat it.
If they don't,
then you finish it and gain a few more pounds like a dad.
Right.
Um,
I dunno.
And I,
I saw,
I also just like,
if your kid fucks up and then you put it on the Internet,
it's just like,
it,
it exists forever and kids are already made.
You're literally giving like,
um,
ammunition.
Like somebody showed me this video,
this woman or a kid was being a class clown and dancing at school and she gave
him the option.
She says,
I'm either going to give you the belt or you can dance.
So the kid is crying cause he's scared and he's sitting there doing this half as
like dancing while he's crying and everybody thinks it's funny.
It's like this fucking kid has to go to school.
Not to mention you should have hit a kid with a belt.
There's like so many fucking things that are wrong with it.
Um,
I don't know.
So,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't like,
and I think you know,
your instincts that you're that mad that you,
you,
I could feel the anger that you have towards it.
Yeah.
Like you shouldn't do that.
And I imagine with your level of anger,
like some shit was done to you,
um,
as was done to me and I think you go one of two ways.
You either repeat it slash try to take it to the next level or you just go back
to like,
oh,
I remember what that felt like.
I,
yeah,
I'm not doing that.
Why would I do that?
Um,
but you know,
there's a lot of morons that,
um,
you know,
you don't have to be smart to know how to fuck.
That's the thing.
If they just made it like something like,
uh,
like if it was as difficult is,
is getting like a degree in something,
I think the world would be a better place.
But anybody can be good.
But did stared it up,
but I wanted to stick it in there.
And next thing you know,
you have a fucking kid,
you throwing cheese at it and you're filming it.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I it's,
I wouldn't do it.
We'll see.
We'll see what the fallout is,
but my kid's not going to be part of that fucking experiment.
All right.
Premiere league soccer,
soccer is in quotes.
I'm imagining this is a fucking somebody who doesn't live in the u s uh,
hey Billy Ball breaker.
I've been listening for a long time and really enjoy your podcasts,
especially during football season as I find your analysis is put more in
layman's terms for us Brits being a fellow Patriot Fan.
Niosh here also gets me shit as most people follow.
The Seahawks wasn't that interesting.
Hey.
Yeah.
If you don't mind right back and let me know why did they follow the Seahawks?
Is it,
cause it's always cloudy over there and they had the same kind of weather in
Britain as they do in Seattle.
That's really interesting.
Um,
I've enjoyed your recent ramblings about the premier league in Liverpool's
battle with Manchester this year.
So I thought I'd share a few facts you may enjoy.
And Lpwan understand more.
Uh,
Liverpool were actually the more successful team in history with 18 league
titles.
Oh yeah.
The,
I heard about this,
this is like before the premiere league existed,
it's almost like pre Superbowl era.
They had five Europe Aka,
so 18 league titles,
five European titles and a bunch of other cups until recently when their biggest
rivals,
Manchester United over took them and have 20 titles,
but only three European titles.
So that's basically the Celtics and Lakers of a premier league football.
Um,
given your gripe about the Steelers,
I thought you'd be interested to know that all 18 of Liverpool's titles were
before the Premiere League era,
but are still very much counted here as it should be.
Yes,
it should.
Uh,
their Wikipedia page is very interesting as they have also faced tragedies along
with other clubs and still cake out on top.
Never heard that expression unless you,
that's a typo.
Secondly,
a man,
man city are only recently a good team as 10 years ago they were about,
they were,
well,
I think he missed a word here as 10 years ago.
They were about over by Arab.
I think they were bought out his what he wanted Eric Billionaires and if
basically play paid extraordinary amounts of money for the best players and are
still not quite good enough to win all the cups.
See this is,
this is what you need to get into it.
It's already a beautiful game and now all I need is the,
the backstory and the drama.
So I think that's really interesting that man city,
all of a sudden they have all this money.
Um,
which who gives a fuck,
cause you know,
before then everyone was probably going to man United or Liverpool if they
wanted to win a title.
Now here they come out of nowhere.
I like it.
It's good.
You know,
you guys all got money.
The Boston Red Sox on the Liverpool,
God knows they got fucking more money than God.
Um,
what about man United?
Did they got a bunch of money?
But that legacy,
I feel like they need to do something soon or all of a sudden it starts to fade
a little bit.
Like the Michigan Wolverines,
like thank God they got a,
what's his face there?
Captain?
Come back to save the end.
He did.
Even though he hasn't beaten Ohio state yet,
uh,
Harbaugh's saved that fucking program because you can only be bad for so long.
We're all this.
If you suck for kids in a recruits entire life,
they don't give a shit that becomes beetle ever.
Stuff like,
yeah,
whatever,
that's yellow submarine football.
I don't give a fuck about it.
And they're going to end up like Oregon came out of nowhere cause all of a
sudden they started having these cool uniforms and started winning games.
Um,
Abbott on a total tangent here.
So let's see.
Here we go.
Thirdly,
going on what you said about the offsides rule and the defending player slowing
down,
they can do this,
but if the attacking player is behind them,
when the ball is played,
they are still on side and can score.
Wait,
how does that work?
The attacking player is behind them.
When the ball is played,
what does that mean?
He ran past him with the ball.
He can't go past the last defender without the ball.
Right?
So the attacker must time they're run with the are.
There are other players making the past and the defending players must do the
same but also be aware that if they get,
oh I see what you're saying.
So like if he's like parallel
to um,
or is it perpendicular fees parallel to the defenseman and somebody kicks the
ball,
pass through the defenseman,
he can take off as the ball's kicked and then he won't,
he'll still be on site.
I get that.
All right.
That's a little more,
uh,
okay.
I guess.
So it's sort of like a moving blue line I guess.
I really appreciate you taking the time to explain this to me though.
Um,
so let me read that again.
Slowly when the ball is played that means kicked,
I guess then they are still on the outside and kids scores.
So the way of way,
way where the fuck was.
Thirdly going on,
what you said about the offsides rule and the defending players slowing down,
they can do this,
but if the attacking player is behind them,
when the ball is played,
meaning kicked,
then they are still on site and can score.
So the attacker must time they're run with their other player.
I like that.
There's a finesse to that.
I have to respect making the pass.
Oh,
do you have to respect it?
You fucking arrogant cunt.
Whatever.
I'm trying to be nicer.
And then defending players must do the same but also be aware that if they get,
if they get wrong,
they have to chase back and stopped the goal.
There are also other factors such as the other player isn't involved in the
play.
He is an offside and can stand anywhere.
All right.
Apologies for the length.
Nah Man,
you actually cleared it up a little bit more.
I still don't think I 100% understand it cause I don't know how far away you
have to be from the play and stuff and you can still be on side.
Um,
hope you found this interesting and please do a show and either Belfast or
Dublin so I can go.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
I was out in Dublin last June.
I haven't been at Belfast in,
in a little bit,
but,
um,
I have to tell you how excited the two tours I've done this year through Europe.
It's been incredible.
And,
um,
I got one more that starts in Iceland at the end of April.
And,
um,
all it's,
I don't know,
it's just incredible.
The people showing up,
the venues I get to play too.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno,
I'm still kind of a blown away by that,
so I'm looking forward to it and I still am kept not been down to Australia.
I keep saying if something always ends up coming up against,
got some active work and to push some dates,
but,
um,
after I do my next year up run the next one I do,
I have to go back to Australia because I haven't been there in a couple of
years.
Um,
all right.
And now I just take the specials and I got to build a fucking hour back up again
and I can't go over there when it's weak.
I gotta make sure,
you know,
cause those eyes,
these fucking people don't screw around.
Right.
Um,
so I gotta make sure it's where it needs to be,
but I will figure all of this up.
All right.
Um,
all right.
By neural,
I'll beats
R A.
L.
Beats.
Dear Bill,
have you heard of binary?
I'll beets.
They're a great alternative to silent meditation and have the same benefits.
All you need is a nice pair of headphones and Youtube on your phone.
Just wanted to let you know,
because I'm also an angry cunt sometimes.
Um,
I found these and they really help with every negative emotion.
They are even a few.
There are even a few that apparently help with migraines.
Check them out.
Thanks for the laughs.
Is this a real thing?
Is this a thing?
Let me see.
Here we go.
Let me right.
Let me,
let me,
let me look this up here.
B I.
N.
U.
A.
R.
L for the people looking at it up to beats.
All right.
Um,
all right,
this is for meditation is three hours and 15 minutes.
We'll see.
We'll little listen to a little bit of this.
Vegetarians LV early.
Eat French fries.
Dot Day.
Here we go.
Here's some buying urial beats.
[inaudible]
sounds like a horror movie.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
all right.
You know,
I can get it to that.
Start off a little scary.
Started off.
Alumni can lie to you.
I was a little,
little e.
Oh,
speaking of scary movies,
if you fuck,
did you see Jordan peals the trailer for his new movie?
That movie looks so scary.
I'm almost angry at him because I've got,
I'm going to go see it.
I saw that and he was like,
oh my God.
And I was like,
dude,
fuck that movie.
Fuck that.
I'm going to go see it.
But Jesus Christ.
Oh my God,
I fucking hate scary movies,
but I love Jordan.
So I'm going to go see that movie.
And I also love,
this is um,
the last one he did sell,
but like this one looks like it's just full on fucking horror and uh,
I don't need that,
but you know,
I'm going to go see it.
Alright.
Boyfriend's family is silent during dinner.
We should go see it.
Me In d and then we'll come on the podcast and talk about it.
She'll be like,
oh my God,
I love that.
I love being scared and I'll be fucking pissed that I went through that shit.
You know,
I told you when I saw it,
when I saw the Blair witch,
I had a set at the laugh factory and I went to the moon like the midnight
showing by myself.
And then I walked down to the parking garage
by myself to the car.
Just totally freaked off like Josh,
Josh.
Like
I know I,
I'm not one of those people that could just sit there and be like,
this is the movie I fucking buy in and it's scares the shit out of me.
Um,
all right.
Boyfriend's family is silent during dinner.
Okay.
Let's see.
Well,
what do we do with this one dear bill,
I need some advice about a guy I've been seeing who is great,
but it's family are kind of strange.
They are lovely and quite nice,
but they are incredibly awkward when together as a family.
It's not that they say or do weird things,
it's that we basically sit in the silence when we're together.
When I first met him,
when I first met them,
Jesus Christ,
I feel like I should be playing that in meditation music while I fucking
[inaudible] as I read this,
um,
there's nobody there stirring coffee slowly are they are a tea,
whatever it was.
Um,
when I first met them I thought that they must have just came from a funeral
because we went out for lunch and it was eerily silent.
I was trying to be nice and ask a few questions,
but I was just getting one word answers.
I asked my boyfriend about this and he had no idea what I was talking about.
He even started to get a bit defensive.
Oh,
all right,
well there you go.
That's,
that's just how they are.
Um,
we've been dating about six months and I dread seeing that because it feels like
I'm being tortured and,
and threat of speaking.
My boyfriend is completely oblivious to it and loved seeing his family,
which is crazy weird because I would say he is reasonably outgoing and fun when
we go out with a group of friends.
Yeah.
That is what's really fucking weird.
Should I stop seeing him or do you think,
uh,
yeah,
Mr Warden you think would be some good techniques for dealing with them.
Please give me some advice.
Hey,
you're single,
you're not married,
so this is all about you.
All right.
You,
you just have to,
you have to figure out,
do I love this guy?
You haven't even said you loved him.
Am I into this person enough to put up with this?
Like these people,
you have a kid with this guy.
These fucking non talking motherfuckers are coming over to your house.
All right.
It seems like you're early on where you like,
should I stop seeing this guy or should maybe a,
it all depends on how much you liked the guy.
MMM.
That's so,
it's so weird that there,
it's not weird that they're like that and it's not weird that he's oblivious
because,
you know,
your family just seems like your family,
you grew up,
but the fact
that
he loves seeing them,
that's what's weird to me.
Like if they just like a not close,
cold family that barely talks,
like that's usually would mean that,
you know,
I see him once every year,
year and a half.
I come around during the holidays and then that's it.
But the fact that he goes there all the time to sit there and then not say
anything to them,
mmm.
I Dunno,
it starts making me wonder if they're like fucking aliens or something.
They're communicating through the center of their foreheads or some shit.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah,
that's definitely strange.
Um,
and the fact that you're so uncomfortable that now you're thinking maybe there's
some good techniques that you're going to go in there and Dr Phil and fixed the
whole fucking family in one segment,
it's not going to happen.
Um,
so I think you need to,
uh,
you got to make a tough choice there.
All right,
me the is great guy.
Go and try to find another great guy.
You sound like you're still young,
still drafted in the first couple of rounds so there's plenty of good talent
left out there and maybe you could have more of a normal family,
but that is a,
or
you just learn to deal with their creepy horror show fucking vibe.
But
um,
I don't know what good techniques you're going to use to fix that.
Especially when you brought it up to him.
He had no idea what you were talking about and was like defensive about it.
So,
so there is that.
Um,
anyways,
I'm going to try that,
that fucking horror music chanting shit.
Sorry.
You're all,
I think I would actually like this better than
I have a meditation app and it's just this and this guy just keeps talking
throughout being like hello again and welcome to another beautiful day with an
opportunity to clear your mind.
Beditate
I'd like you to find a comfortable chair
and just sit in it,
the other chair
up against your body.
Are there places that it's touching you too much
or does it feel just right?
I'm
fucking that shit and it's just like,
oh my God,
dude,
just shut the fuck up.
All right.
Just tell me to breathe and that just shut up please.
For the love of God shut up.
So I think I would rather,
rather than listen to that guy,
I'd rather listen to this shit.
[inaudible]
Josh,
I don't mean to end this so fucking in such a creepy Goddamn web.
Um,
maybe I need to listen to this shit so I can go see Jordan teals,
new fucking movie and not be overly freaked out and traumatized by it.
Um,
how great is it that that guy's making movies is,
it's every once in a,
somebody fucking like that comes along.
It's just awesome.
It's awesome.
If you love movies,
it's fucking awesome.
All right.
That is the,
uh,
that is the podcast.
Ladies a gentleman.
I'll check it on ya on Thursday.
Go Bruins,
go Celtics.
Um,
if anybody knows how,
if I can watch a replay of the moto GP race,
I would love to watch it.
Um,
send it to my Twitter account,
please let me know.
I would love to see it.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll see you on Thursday.